[موسيقى]
توقعنا بانه ستكون هنالك
تردي في الاوضاع الاقتصاديه ولكني لطالما
توقعت بان
توقعات الانخفاض الحاده كان مبالغ فيها
اولا لان روسيا
اعتادت على التعامل مع العقوبات منذ عام
2014 منذ حادثه القرن فحصل التعديلات
كثيره في الاقتصاد الروسي عبر 8 سنوات
الماضيه وكانوا يستعدون للمزيد من
الاكتفاء الذاتي
والتنويع الاقتصاد
ونشاط الاقتصاديه وخاصه في المسارات
التجاريه على سبيل المثال في عام 2013
قبل بدا العقوبات
روسيا لم تقم ببيع اي نفط او غاز مباشره
الى الصين اما في العام الماضي او قبل عام
من الان الصين كانت اكبر مشتري للغاز او
الروسي خاصه عبر انابيب الغاز الرئيسيه
وكذلك مشترك كبير لالغاز
وفحم والمواد الاخرى
فمساله التنويع حصلت اصلا
فكنا اتوقع انخفاض في الاقتصاد وقد
تفاجاتم
الى اي مدى تحسن الاداء واعتقد
ان هذا ناجم عن حقيقه ان
روسيا كسبت اموال اكثر بكثير من التصيد
النفط والغاز والفحم والمواد الاخرى
لان اوروبا بكل بساطه ما عدا تحمل تكلفه
فرضي العقوبات على هذه المواد بسرعه كبيره
لانهم كانوا يعتمدون على روسيا بشكل كبير
جدا
اولا نتذكر بان هيكليه الاقتصاد الروسي
تختلف كثيرا
عن ايام التحسس السابقه مع اقصدهم بان
قطاعات الدوله او الدوله بنفسها تهيمن على
الاقتصاد اكثر من ثلثيه الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي تحت سيطره الدوله بشكل او باخر
وهكذا كان الدوله تمكن من المحافظه على
النمو العام من خلال ضخ الاموال الى
قطاعات الدوله ولكن اذا نظرنا خارج هذه
الصوره مثلا صنعت السيارات وقطاع
الاستهلاكي او التكنولوجيا او القطاعات
الجديده
فمساله الضعف كانت شديده مثلا
تنخفضت بنسبه 40% في العام الماضي وحتى
مبيعات الاستهلاكيه والمفرق انخفضت بعشره
بالمئه فهي ليست صوره موحده للاقتصاد
باكمله بل ان هيكليه الاقتصاد الروسي
[موسيقى]
خلال الازمات تتمكن فيها الحكومه بكل
سهوله من تحقيق الاستقرار على ارقام
رئيسيه ولكن هنالك يتنوعات كثيره غير ذلك
عبر القطاعات المختلفه كما ذكرنا من
الاقتصاد
[موسيقى]